The joe rogan experience.
Do you remember?
We've had phone at envy for so long
mean you like you would have like the,
the east seven 15.
We're like,
oh my God,
they just released the eight 15,
like the Motorola flip phone,
stupid phones.
But I took a great fucking picture with
that phone when the greatest pictures
that ever took him out of the booker,
the hooker when we're
working in downtown La.
And uh,
it's not the downtown La of today,
which is,
what's that word?
What's that word when they move into
a neighborhood gentrify black cloud,
black cloud or wipe out?
This woman was walking by and she was
heating a meatball sub and she had a wig
on and she was an overweight
African American hooker.
And a,
I looked at her and she goes,
how are you doing?
I go,
what's up baby?
And she pulls a tid out as I'm taking
a picture of her with a meatball sub in
one hand and a tit and the other.
And it's perfectly framed.
Like if I was a conspiracy theorist,
I would say,
well,
this was fake.
This is obviously Photoshop.
This never really took place.
Do you think it's perfectly frank?
I think it's online,
right?
You find it,
pull it,
pull it up.
Oh,
with a woman's breast.
It's not even pornographic.
The wellness,
disturbing.
Looking like it can see a male's breasts.
Why can't you see a woman's for us?
You know what's fascinating?
You can see Chazz Palminteri is brass.
Did you know that?
Yes.
Not Chazz.
Palminteri Chaz Bono.
I get them confused.
The Bronx style.
I bet you could see his as well.
He's a man.
No disrespect to Mr Palminteri.
It was just slip.
I meant Chaz Bono who used to be used to
be chastity Bono and then it's a famous
daughter of share and got a sex change
while there was like these photos of her
walking down the beach topless
because now she's a man.
Now she's got like a beard,
so she's allowed to walk topless,
so she's taking advantage of that and
she's walking topless and she's good.
That's her.
That's the girl.
That's the lady that is a real picture.
Pulled that shit up all the way.
USTREAM was with us.
Don't worry.
Brattle Brad will be fine with it.
Dot.
Don't do it,
Brian.
Just show them.
Show them the meatball sub,
just the meatball sub and a hand.
Come on.
How does that happen?
Photos.
Perfectly framed.
Listen,
do you,
can you can Photoshop one,
make a copy of that,
make a copy of that and just put
a little blurry on the nipple
that only take you a
second to do it right.
Can you do that Brian?
Like there's like five guys.
That's amazing picture.
Come on that as the picture and that you
can see we had a block out the nipple
because apparently it almost sunk CBS
when Janet Jackson whipped went out.
Who knows what it could do to Ustream,
but this,
uh,
this lady with her 10 out,
I did not ask her to do this.
Okay.
This was the universe giving me a gift.
No.
Well,
yes and no.
It wasn't cee lo green the whole time.
Yes and no.
It did not turn me on.
It did not turn me on sexually,
but it did turn me on socially because
I knew I was going to post this online
and people are going to go bananas.
I was very excited.
I was like,
I have to show people this is
going to give them great joy.
I think this is the part where
he started to lose his mind.
Yeah,
I remember.
I remember
Ryan.
Do you think she's alive now?
Cause that was like 2005
if you had to guess,
do you think that women's
have meatball subs every day?
I'm sure there's some
Italians live forever.
Do they think God motherfuckers
they live forever.
That's good to know,
but that was a real moment for me.
It was a,
it was a great,
great moment for me.
I wish you had that on video though.
That would,
yeah,
it would be.
It would be awesome.
D G Galaxy s three video.
Yeah,
but then she probably sue me.
I wonder if she knows
the picture's out there.
Oh,
I wonder if someone was like,
girl,
do you know to your pictures online,
your titties out,
you got a meatball sub.
That ain't even me.
My wig don't look nothing like that.
That is not me.
That is not me,
girl.
I'm telling you.
That was a veggie saying no.
Did they ask pictures of you?
You got your titty out and uh,
meet Moss.
I'll be your hand and bitch.
You look fat.
You look like bigfoot earthquake gut.
Oh,
that's a gut.
I'm a person who doesn't give a fuck.
She doesn't give a fuck.
I didn't access a Dick.
That's all it takes.
That's a real tip,
bro.
Look at it
like that on a man.
A fake tits on men always look odd
and the nipples were never big enough.
And you know that that
nipples the correct size.
I never knew.
I never knew how to start.
I don't hear anything Brian.